Facebook just announced what it calls a
major overhaul to its privacy features
the changes make it easier to block apps
from user data and make privacy tools
easier to find CBS News learned CEO Mark
Zuckerberg will likely testify before
Congress about Facebook's privacy
policies after more than 50 million
users data was obtained by Cambridge
analytical addameer duthiers of our
streaming network cbsn is following the
story of lag good morning good morning
this comes a day after a lawsuit filed
in California claims Facebook improperly
stores call logs on synced Android
phones Facebook says it only stores that
data on certain apps when users opt in
and as calls mount for Zuckerberg to
answer for these controversies it
appears the often private CEO isn't
opting out will you testify before
Congress so the short answer is is
unhappy to if it's the right thing to do
after signaling his willingness last
week Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg seems
ready to follow through his company is
under intense scrutiny following
accusations that it mishandled a
personal data of more than 50 million
Facebook users which ended up with
British data firm Cambridge analytical
since the scandal broke Facebook stock
has tumbled by more than 17 percent and
the FTC has opened an investigation into
the company's practices in response to
concerns Facebook announced this morning
it is consolidating privacy tools onto a
single page and allowing users to choose
which apps use their data this doesn't
change any of the data that Facebook's
actually collecting Kurt Wagner is
senior editor of social media at recode
he believes the real sign of change at
Facebook is at CEOs behavior no it does
feel like this is a bigger moment than
we've seen in the past from some of
these tech companies mark zuckerberg may
now testify in front of Congress like
these are real consequences of what's
going on until now Zuckerberg and other
tech CEOs have generally sent lawyers or
deputies to testify before Congress I
would like to mis see mr. Zuckerberg not
his lawyer mr. Zuckerberg in the flesh
but the growing course of frustrated
lawmakers and users seems to have forced
a new course of action he knows that if
he
doesn't do it he's gonna just get
absolutely crushed by the media by
politicians possibly most importantly
perhaps to him by Facebook's users
Facebook tells us this morning that it
is looking into the claims in the
California lawsuit no date has been
announced yet for Zuckerberg testimony
all right Vlad thank you so much